Part C a researcher estimates that in a
certain organism the complete metabolism
of glucose produces 30 molecules of ATP
for each molecule of glucose the energy
released from the total oxidation of
glucose under standard conditions is 686
kilocalories per mole the energy
released from the hydrolysis of ATP to
ADP and inorganic phosphate under
standard conditions is 7.3 kilocalories
per mole calculate the amount of energy
available from the hydrolysis of 30
moles of ATP calculate the efficiency of
total ATP production from one mole of
glucose in the organism describe what
happens to the excess energy that is
released from the metabolism of glucose
all right I'm tired of squeezing things
in between the questions so let me go
down here to get some real estate so
let's do the first part let's calculate
the amount of energy available from the
hydrolysis of 30 moles of ATP so let me
write this hydrolysis hydrolysis of 30
moles of ATP so I'll draw this how I got
the title right over there so let's just
take 30 moles 30 30 moles of ATP times
they tell us how much energy is released
when you hydrolyze that ATP per mole
they say the energy released from the
hydrolysis of ATP let me underline that
the energy released from the hydrolysis
of ATP to ADP and inorganic phosphate
under standard conditions is 7.3
kilocalories per mole since 30 we have
30 moles that's getting high that is
that is that is go undergoing hydrolysis
and so 30 moles times seven point three
kilocalories kilocalories per mole and
what is that going to be equal to well
the moles cancel with the moles the
units are going to be kilocalories which
makes sense because I want units of
energy and what is 30 times 7.3 see
three times seven point three would be
twenty one point nine so this is going
to be two hundred and
19 since it's 30 times 7.3 219
kilocalories alright and now let's do
the second part now I'll do this in a
different color you're actually taking
the test you might not get the benefit
of multiple colors but this is for you
de to help me help you understand what's
going on calculate the efficiency of
total ATP production from one mole of
glucose in the organism so I'll do that
over here efficiency efficiency is
actually let me do it well efficiency is
equal to energy is going to be energy in
ATP energy stored in ATP over total
energy total energy from oxidation
energy from oxidation of glucose so the
K say calculate the efficiency of total
eighty production ATP production from
one mole of glucose in the organism so
this is going to be equal to so they
tell us what the energy production when
you oxidize one mole of glucose they say
it is 686 kilocalories per mole so the
denominator here is 686 kilocalories and
the numerator the energy stored in ATP
will for this particular organism it is
able to produce 30 ATP's it the the
complete metabolism of glucose produces
30 molecules of ATP so for every mole of
glucose is producing 30 moles of ATP and
so we already figured that's going to be
219 kilocalories 219 kilocalories so now
we just have to do a little bit of math
here to figure out what 219 divided by
686 is going to be let me do it over
here 686 divided by 200 sorry 219
divided by 686 this is going to be less
than zero so let me go straight to how
many times with 686 go into 2,100 and
90 well this is a little bit less than
seven hundred and seven times three is
twenty-one so this looks like about
three times 3 times 6 is 18 3 times 8 is
24 plus 1 is 25 3 times 6 is 18 plus 2
is 20 let me subtract it
let's see 90 minus 58 is 32 so I have
132 then I can bring down another 0 686
well let's see it looks like this might
be one or two times I see 2 times 686
would be 1200 is actually going to be
one time by feeling well maybe we'll
round up it sounds like so one times 686
is 686 you subtract all right I will do
some regrouping here so I can make this
a 10 this a 1 so 10 minus 6 is 4 now I
can make this a 2 and this 1 11 11 minus
8 is 3 and then 12 minus 6 is 6 so 686
goes into six thousand three hundred and
forty this is definitely going to be
more than five times so if we want to
approximate we would round up this is
going to be approximate so there's going
to be something else that is greater
than five so it's going to be
approximately 32 percent so I can write
it let me write it here so this is
approximately 32 percent efficiency so
roughly 32 percent of the potential
energy or of all the energy that can be
produced from the oxidation of glucose
actually ends up getting stored in ATP
now they say describe what happens I'm
just in another color for fun describe
what happens to the excess energy that
is released from the metabolism of
glucose yet what happens to what happens
to the other 68% of the energy so I'll
do it over here the rest of the energy
is released as heat the rest of energy
gets converted or goes is is is is
released
released as heat and you could say it's
also released as entropy increasing the
number of possible states of the cells
more things or bouncing around in
different ways
but this is the easiest way to think
about it is released a seat in general
when you think about any thermodynamic
process you think about the efficiency
new thing but where where is all of that
lost energy that wasn't captured it's
usually going to be it's usually going
to be Heat
all right now let's do Part D Part D the
enzymes of the Krebs cycle function in
the cytosol of bacteria but among
eukaryotes the enzymes function mostly
in the mitochondria
all right mostly in the mitochondrion
organelle pose a scientific question
that connects the sub cellular location
of the enzymes in the krebs cycle to the
evolution of eukaryotes
all right well and we've talked about it
when we talked about when we first
talked about mitochondria on on Khan
Academy but their directory is a theory
that that mitochondria you or the
ancestors of mitochondria you might have
been independent prokaryotic organisms
so we could say the scientific question
we could say were the ancestors of
mitochondria mitochondria once
independent in day independent
independent because they even say well
prokaryotic Pro carry otic carry otic
organisms whose descendants lived
learned whose descendants became
incorporated in eukaryotic organisms
whose descendants descendants the
descend descendants whose descendants
became became incorporated became
incorporated corporated inside
eukaryotes you carry its so that's a
scientific question and a really
interesting one that you know if you
look at any cell and in the human body
you're actually going to you're going to
see these mitochondria are actually in
the great majority of cells and where
their ancestors wants independent
organisms that now have their who's a
whose descendants now live in symbiosis
with ourselves because they're so good
at the Krebs cycle